good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Tuesday another
beautiful day here in New York City hey
Claude how are you doing I don't want to
trigger people with how you learn well I
think you just did I'm doing good
I'm you know crampon I'm on my third
cycle of quarantine I'm feeling moody
feeling a little PMS II and ready to
take it out on you know the toast nice
well me and snitch are then completely
synced up on our times of the month so
that's an interesting quarantine
development I wonder if any of the
toasters are cycled up with us let's go
so yeah that would just be so fun for
for the community yeah you know we have
this like deep bond within our community
and I think us also you know syncing up
cycles would be just the thing we need
to take us to the next level
I completely agree um I'm sorry that
you're in the cramp phase though I
passed through it on Sunday pass through
to the other side and and I'm feeling
better yeah I'm in the cramp and also
the weird [ __ ] dream phase um I had
the weirdest dream last night all about
lizards and like the whole night I felt
like they were lizards in my bed it was
not good oh that's really creepy
I had a dream but it was more realistic
but now I'm losing it
damn it was it sounds like what Martin
Luther King would have said I had a
dream a dream so there's like not a lot
of news today but we'll do what we can
actually is oh there was I actually had
to you know eliminate some stories
there's some decent celebrity news I
watched a good amount of TV last night
oh my god I watched song land oh my god
I'm so behind I forgot to put a watch
don't let me forget to talk about it was
Florida Georgia line and it's giving Old
Dominion competition for best episode
ever like Zack and I were watching it
and we didn't want to end well can we
just wait to recap it tomorrow so I can
watch it okay but you have to watch it
today or else I'm recapping tomorrow
okay I waited a whole week for you to
watch Ted to me and Hollywood like you
know you meet you recapped it I just put
my things
you'd give me a day I want to recap it
together okay I said I'll give you a day
maybe Jim will say a day or else you go
on me that's a fair trade that's fair
cool I also watch more of money hi still
not feeling season four but it's
something to watch I'm like nervous it's
gonna end soon and then I have to get it
into like a whole new world of something
and I'm just I'm running low my sidewalk
was so full and now it's so empty and
this is what I feared
that's what quarantine is all about like
having a full plate and then an empty
plate I watch Tom Jerry Seinfeld's
comedy special and boy do I have
thoughts okay share for the save it for
the recap segment but I'm probably won't
watch so I want to hear what you think
yeah no I am have a lot to say okay
great and what else did I do yesterday
actually in a really busy day we were
according to patreon episode of all dear
toasters we got such good inquiries I
hope people got some good advice and are
gonna make some changes and then he went
snitch recorded a Taylor Swift scene
episode that is dropping today
had it been dropped I dropped it this
morning already oh it was good but you
know so many of the questions at me and
Margo got we're like ranked this album
ranked all of her albums ranked your
favorite songs and those questions are
like so impossible and I hate doing
rankings because of course no matter
what like something has to go at the
bottom and that implies somehow that
it's like bad or negative when nothing
she does is bad they're just things I
like more than others so I have a lot of
anxiety about rankings and that was like
all the questions that we got and I
tried to answer like every other
question besides the ranking ones but
ultimately we had to rank all the albums
and like I don't even stand by what I
said because I like them all I feel like
ranking her albums though is is possible
and it doesn't mean the one at the
bottom is bad it just means that you
prefer the one at the top but I don't
want to say something because it's
ever-changing like for the last maybe
two or three years 1989 has been my
favorite album but forever it was read
so it's like with it with different
phases of my life I just can't make a
decision so I recently cleaned my
apartment to the soundtrack of the red
album because that's always what I
thought was my favorite album of hers
and what I thought was just the best
album ever but I think it was just I was
listening to it during one of the best
times of my life
and the whole time like it's funny when
you listen to her music like I'm
transported to what she was doing and
I'm just like Ethel Kennedy the Kennedys
every Jewish like the red album is like
at an American history album about the
Kennedy family I couldn't [ __ ] get
Ethel Kennedy out of my head
ya know we said the same thing about how
like different albums like I've been a
Taylor fan for so long and part of why I
love her so much is that different
albums remind me of both of times of her
life but also times of mine like I just
remembered listening to read my first
year of college I was living out of my
house like I was in a dorm like I just
associate memories with the album's um
but you know what red was my favorite
for so long probably because like it was
such a good year of my life when I go
back it's actually not my favorite like
of course there's red state of grace
like amazing stables but there's
actually like a lot of skips on that
album for me like I don't love lucky
ones or I almost do like I actually skip
a good amount of songs but see I still
like those songs like I'm not saying I
don't like them I'm just saying I skip I
hear no like I thought red was the mat
like the best album and then I listened
to it in 2020 maybe just 20 20 ruins
everything and I was like oh this
definitely isn't my favorite album in
some ways I actually like reputation
more well so Margo is like a reputation
stain'd and I am a 1989 apologist so it
was just a very dynamic in-depth
conversation that I said formalin so
what was your can you give us a spoil
what was your top album and love with
snitches 1989 1989 um and then it was
Speak Now and then it was lover and then
it was um red and then it was I'm
forgiving one whatever Margo's top o
fear oh you know I don't even [ __ ]
remember it's so hard it's so hard
Margo's top was um speak now okay I feel
that for her I feel that for her too and
by the way there's it just depends where
I am like if I am in a mountain lodge
then speak now is my vibe but if I'm on
like a boat in the middle of Turks and
Caicos like lover is my vibe it's just
different scenarios it really is it's it
I don't envy the task because honestly
even as
one who like doesn't who feels
comfortable saying negative things about
Taylor I am having a hard time putting
this together as well so and i listening
that episode like spiraled me for the
rest of the day like I literally sat in
bed and watch videos of Taylor Swift
like I might live on mice 50 account
like I literally was the least
productive person all day after that
episode just because like I got in my
own fandom and I couldn't get out of it
but that sounds like a good place to be
like I love good rabbit-hole during the
Q don't get me out don't come and get me
don't come and get me don't come for me
unless I stand for you a hundred percent
okay we also have a lot of interesting
guests this week they're not coming til
the end of the week but tomorrow we're
gonna sit down for an episode on
Thursday with Lauren gray who we are
obsessed with I'm so [ __ ] excited we
have been like standing her since before
like tick tock was a thing it was
musically like especially Margo like
we've been obsessed search is a new song
coming out so I'm really excited shocked
her like maybe we'll get some tick-tock
followers from it and then on Thursday
we're recording for Friday's Oh No yeah
Thursday for Friday's episode we're
recording with Leah McSweeney from real
houses in New York which like I'm not
well not well not well not well I'm so
excited it's been a while since we've
had guests and in the queue like I just
when we have a guest it's someone that
I'm legit dying to talk to you so these
two these two queens
I can't wait you know just a couple of
blonde Queens totally um okay so maybe
it's time I think so I think so okay
without further ado et's time for the
past five stories that you need to know
yeah you before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast and while
I have you allow me just a brief moment
to remind everyone that today's episode
is brought to you yes it's true by
Nature iam driven by the belief that
high-performance skincare should and can
be non-toxic skin compatible and
affordable the tram was born their
mission is to create safe clinically
effective biocompatible products that
deliver visible results all of their
products range from 16 to 25 dollars yet
they're as effective as formulas that
are triple or in some cases 18 times the
price nutriyums formulas utilize
cutting-edge technologies to harness the
healing powers of ingredients found in
nature
all of their products are proudly made
in the USA they are cruelty free paraben
free gluten free non-toxic fragrance
free and dermatologist tested they
believe it's impossible to achieve
healthy nourish skin with formulas that
are unbalanced or incompatible they only
use ingredients that are either directly
benefiting the skin or they support the
integrity of the formulas with hundreds
of ingredients banned on their know list
and an in-depth online ingredient
library and at Ram's number one priority
is safety and transparency Jackie and I
got so many products from them like
months ago now and we've been using them
for a while we both have been loving the
multi peptide eye cream but they have
tons of products for whatever your skin
needs are they really it's fabulous
having using them all during the queue
and I've been getting a lot of
compliments on my skin I use the retinol
serum oil and face cream and the vitamin
C serum and oil and the multi peptide
eye cream I also have oh I also use
their like green green stuff face wash
it's good green stuff face wash um we
have a special promo for toasters who
want to receive the free multi peptide
eye cream that we were just talking
about with any purchase of two items you
have to go to Natori I'm calm that's na
T URI um add an eye cream to any
purchase of two items or more by using
code toast so you got to buy two items
putting Co toast and you'll get a free
multi peptide eye cream for no cost to
thank Unitarian for sponsoring today's
episode I didn't realize that Natori 'im
its products found from nature yes they
put the nature in the Turia sinon get
products on from nature
okay first story um Ryan Seacrest quote
did not have any kind of stroke during
the American Idol finale says his rep
have you seen this story yes I happen to
catch the tail end of the American Idol
finale just because it was on right
before Taylor Swift concert on ABC and
it was really um really sad like the
whole thing was done via zoom and the
winner won and I think that the other
person who was up for the number one
spot might have misheard because him and
his family started celebrating with
champagne and I was incredibly confused
and then they all just started singing
on and putting their faces on buildings
and it made no goddamn sense um but I
didn't see the clip of Ryan Seacrest
allegedly like looking drunk okay but
you know what if you saw
clip where the winner won you actually
did see the clip that everyone's talking
about um while American Idol crowned
Samantha just Sam D as the season's
winner during the show's live remote
finale on Sunday night it was Idol host
Ryan Seacrest who found himself sharing
some of the spotlight towards the end of
the show which had seen Seacrest nimbly
juggling on-air hosting duties as
contestants appeared remotely from their
homes the star briefly appeared off his
words seemed slightly slurred and his
right eye appeared larger than his left
the moment prompted a flurry of Twitter
comments from fans concerned that
Seacrest was not well or had suffered
some kind of neurological episode so he
definitely did see the thing that people
are talking about but you probably
didn't notice it I watched it like
having read this headline and now I'm
like okay I guess that does look a
little strokey but I probably I thought
it was gonna be way more obvious than it
was but I guess throughout the night he
was having you know technical
difficulties and just stumbling over his
words and people thought he might have
been drunk but his rep said Ryan Ryan
did not have any kind of stroke last
night like many people right now Ryan is
adjusting to the new normal and finding
work home balance with the added stress
of having to put on live shows from home
between live with Kelly and Ryan
American Idol on Air with Ryan Seacrest
and the Disney family sing-along
specials he has been juggling three or
four on-air jobs over the last few weeks
and he's in need of rest so today he
took a well-deserved day off oh my god
ever needs to chill the [ __ ] out like
Ryan Seacrest is the hardest [ __ ]
working man in Hollywood during the
normal days he's going back and forth
from New York to LA luckily the [ __ ]
alone he's tired from literally putting
the entire media industry on his [ __ ]
back okay I was watching Shahs of Sunset
and it said produced by Ryan Seacrest
okay he's busy yeah he's very busy he's
probably exhausted um ergo one eye is
bigger than the other you know is having
one eye bigger than the other is a crime
and put me in jail
lock me up okay okay everyone is so like
nitpicky about people it's like
everyone's so bored and like just leave
him alone I know but people also live
for this [ __ ] like you know a video goes
viral someone acts imperfect and then
we're picking it up everywhere to the
point that his rap nice so let us know
that we didn't witness a stroke well
this is like a similar situation like
when pee
some odd behavior in Michael bublé's
Instagram live in regards to his wife
and that I felt as though was cause for
concern but I haven't seen this video
but it's just like his eye looked big
are we seriously that specific okay so
first of all it's I guess is a similar
situation because it's like two videos
that people have questions about but
like they're so different
yes his I looked honestly it wasn't that
concerning his eyes looked big he at
some point like seemed like he was just
about to stop talking completely um he
was moving very lethargic Lee but maybe
he was just lethargic I mean it wasn't
exactly the most exciting finale of
American Idol like I can imagine Ryan
Seacrest sitting at his [ __ ] dining
room table for two hours talking to
nobody
maybe he gets a little bored and he
yawns and his eye bulges a little bit
like I just listen he works so hard like
I do one show a day and I'm exhausted
like he does four and maybe at the last
show the finale of American Idol where
people's Holograms are singing on
[ __ ] billboards he got a little tired
yeah totally I can't believe that they
did the rest of this season of American
Idol virtually and honestly if it hadn't
been for Ryan Seacrest faked stroke I
would have never even heard of just Sam
I would have no clue who won no and if
it weren't for Taylor Swift city of
lubber concert I wouldn't have even
tuned in to know that a American Idol is
still on the air
- they're filming about finale and three
tonight's the finale I'm like wow I'm
catching it I literally was there and
the winner is and I'm like how fabulous
is this yeah I guess that was the point
of putting Taylor Swift's concert like
after that - you know drum up some love
for American Idol yeah well Taylor Swift
has now been hospitalized for putting
the American Idol season finale on her
back yeah and she's in the room next to
Ryan Seacrest for having a stroke yeah
and in the other room is Portia from
real houses of Atlanta from putting the
entire franchise on her back for the
last five seasons and then in the room
next to that is Francesca farrago for
two from too hot to handle for putting
the whole show on her back she's having
some back issues and then also down the
hall is bianca del rio from season six
of RuPaul's Drag Race was literally like
the worst group of contestants ever and
she was a star and she deserves better
and she put that entire [ __ ] season on
her back so I'm wishing her a speedy
recovery Wow I mean we're foolishly I'm
onto all of these people in
at least they're together blessings
blessings okay next up it's a story that
is just you know gonna we're gonna close
the loop from something from yesterday
Brian Austin Green has confirmed his
split from Megan Fox after nearly ten
years of marriage it's the end of the
road for Megan Fox and Brian Austin
Green he confirmed on Monday May 18th at
the longtime couple have called it quits
after nearly 10 years of marriage he
revealed the breakup in a new episode of
his podcast who knew he had a podcast
titled context he referenced the photos
of Fox and Machine Gun Kelly that
surfaced over the weekend and revealed
that he had a dream while she was
filming her new movie with the rapper
that there was distance between the two
and noted that since the end of 2019
quote they've really tried there they
really been trying to sort of be apart
okay I feel like these two have been
separated forever like sometimes they
come together like I don't know today
they have kids um but like the messiest
couple in Hollywood a hundred percent
the one that made the least sense and
the one that needed to end ASAP that's
the thing it never made sense and you
sometimes when couples don't make sense
but they stay together for so long like
it starts to make sense and like you you
picture it together but these two just
never really made sense to me like to me
Megan Fox is like the pinnacle of like
sexiness Maxim like everything of the
sort she is like the most desirable
woman in the world objectively and yes
Brian Austin Green burger whatever his
name is like he is handsome but he is by
no means like at the same level and he's
technically look if you look him up in
the dictionary it says Brian Austin
Green has been like he doesn't really
work anymore
so I just never really understood the
pairing and you would think like after
they've been together for 10 years their
kids say the family like they're working
through like you would think I would
start to like you know get on the ship
but it never really came in yeah oh my
god it never came in I kept on hoping
that every time I heard about these two
like it would have been over by now
and now it's finally over he said I will
always love her and I know she will
always love me and I know as far as
family what we have built is really cool
and really special he explained that
they will still do family vacations and
holidays as a family and really make
that a focus for the kids
lovely hopefully the kids are fans of
Machine Gun Kelly because he's good
right coming around so like normally I'm
not really like excited at the prospect
of like a family
you know breaking our parents kids
involved but at the same time I'm like
too excited about the prospect of
Machine Gun Kelly and Megan Fox till I
give a [ __ ] about these kids like this
is fabulous Megan Fox's time is coming
like she was whistling for 10 years who
just wasn't on her level and now she's
with it's probably such a different
feeling for her like me with someone on
her level you know yeah for sure is
someone who like together they will rise
you know because like she's I haven't
heard from her in a while like we're on
koalas I'm the Wallis department store
it's like she's been kind of quiet and I
feel like her and Machine Gun Kelly I
was just gonna both be taken to another
level from this relationship and I feel
like he'll be he's a good stepdad to the
kids so the kids don't even looked after
like the campers we'll be fine
like Machine Gun Kelly is that I'll
never forget the first time I saw
Machine Gun Kelly because when I was an
intern at AOL they put on this like
interview series where they were to make
celebrities to do press and like nobody
watched it but like it was still like
cool cuz they got cool people and
Machine Gun Kelly came and normally
nobody really showed up to these things
but he had promoted it on his social
media this was like like six years ago
so he had like a really like tumblr you
like really underground following and
all these people showed up to the
corporate AOL headquarters like spiky
hair tattoos like it was just like Daddy
chokers like it was just crazy and he
came into the interview and literally
stopped the interview in the middle took
his shirt off started rapping screaming
in the middle of a corporate office like
all these people were like jumping
crowd-surfing
it was the craziest thing I'd ever seen
and I was like damn who is this he's
kind of hot
then he resurfaced with that whole
Camila Cabello song and it was such a
good song like literally one of her best
opportunites Ungh then he resurfaced as
being like the man who picked up the
pieces from ariana grande breaking Pete
Davidson's heart brought Pete Davidson
to LA when he was in a very low point in
his life brought him to the Golden
Globes like Oscar party and he's just to
me I've seen him in so many different
phases of his life and I've respected
him ever since so like I'm just excited
about this I'm excited about this I
never had an opinion about him until the
movie with Petey butts in that we just
watched adult adult and I was saying wow
he's a handsome fella ya know he's very
handsome but like he's like a little
rough around the edges right now like
when you hear about him like he's bad to
the bone and like he's you know edgy but
he's also quite handsome so get you a
guy he would
both Megan Fox has and I I look forward
to watching my ship come in ya know I'm
standing at the port and I'm looking and
it appears to be close to shore so I'm
I'm wearing this nautical shirt today
okay this next story is really sad um so
I'm just gonna transition to sadness
Twilight actor Gregory Tyree boyce and
his girlfriend were found dead in Las
Vegas have you heard the story yes hi
dr. Gregory Tyree Boise and his 27 year
old girlfriend were found dead in the in
their Las Vegas condo last week
according to report on Monday Boise and
Natalie Pegu were pronounced dead on May
13th enews reported their cause of death
is pending a toxicology report as an
actor voice was known for his role in
the first of the Twilight movie
franchise he played tyler Crawley who
has a crush on Christmas Stewart's
character Bella Swan he also appeared in
the short film apocalypse prior to their
deaths they had been working on starting
a wing restaurant according to his
mother who posted a tribute on Facebook
calling him the best chef I read what
his mother posted on Facebook and it was
just so sad I'm she was so heartbroken
it was so excited for about his future
and this is just a really sad and
mysterious story and I just feel so sad
for both of them yeah it's like spooky
you know mm-hmm like Emily's new key
cause of death they both were found to
head it's just it's so weird and it's
really sad because they were so young um
and they loved him in Twilight so really
wishing his family the best this is a
terrible [ __ ] story Sam and I hope
that they get answers soon right um okay
gonna switch gears right again - yes J
ro perto Bear is pregnant and expecting
baby number three
with husband Tanner toll bear wait I
heard that
Jade Roberto Burt was pregnant oh no no
you're confused it's Jade Roberto bear
I'm sorry I got confused with the other
Jade were poor Tolbert ya know you would
think Jade Roper Tolbert might be
pregnant but it's not it's Jade repair
Toby Bell so bad
sorry podcasters Jade preparer
announcement she's pregnant and it's
expecting her third child with husband
Tanner told them after sharing a family
photo along with the pregnancy test and
a sonogram picture on Instagram here we
grow again she captioned it it feels so
good to be able to finally talk about
this pregnancy if you noticed I haven't
been on social media much the past
couple of months it's because I was
dealing with terrible nausea and fatigue
on top of taking care of two kiddos
during a pandemic we are so thankful and
excited for this Babette I truly believe
Bebe's being born during this time are
here for a special reason to be light
workers we are beyond happy to be light
workers the way I said it light to
worker like fixing the lights and they
to the construction site with a drill we
are beyond happy to love another baby to
get Emmy and Brooks another sibling to
have our children be so close oh my god
this is so sweet
there's such a sweet family I love I do
love that your baby news because every
baby that is born it gives like the
franchise another season to you know let
people think that they're doing some
good in the world ya know and it like
outweighs like in the scale like when
you get to heaven and God like ways all
the good things Asia it's like look what
they did they tried to like ruin Olivia
creedy's life but they're responsible
for like 10 kids now so like it kind of
weighs out I guess I mean that's like
Mike faces judgment that is his
crosshair life your inner life creator
does it balance out I actually think it
does you think I don't know means who
are we to judge we are no one to judge
um but in regards to this story look I
know that you're you're like of course
you never know what goes on behind
closed doors like you shouldn't like
really like look at other people's lives
and like want to emulate it like you
should be grateful for what you have but
like I just like think they have the
perfect life and I'm sure that they have
their own [ __ ] but like they're just I
just appears like everything like just
happens for them do you know what I mean
yeah except for just to give you some
perspective of a few things one they won
that draftkings money but then Oh
Tanner's own friend lest we not forget
goose goose of Christmas
Goo's ratted him out and they didn't get
the money it's other thing that I just
like can't get out of my mind no matter
how hard I try they were on marriage
boot camp and they were like fighting in
the room and it was just like they're
just like us you raised some very
interesting points once again aligning
people is nobody's perfect
I had a Montana Senate best nobody's
perfect but I agree with you that they
are goals but like perfect isn't goals
because nobody is perfect like they seem
like they have a real true relationship
um their family keeps growing they have
such cute babies and they seem like
overall content with their life and
that's really all you can ask for
remember their pollachi in Kentucky or
Kansas where we're living and now they
live in LA and it's still a palaca it's
like the nicest house I've ever seen I
know but like when they were living in
Appalachia in Kansas and they had a lake
at barns and horses yeah I don't know if
they had horses but it was nice it was
it looks like they had horses yeah I
wonder what happened to that house I
think they were selling it but they
built it from the ground up I remember
she did a YouTube tour and like this is
custom this is a custom couch these are
custom cabinets custom custom custom
five minutes later we're moving to LA
yeah interesting
yeah very loving okay we're a bear -
bear oh is it the fifth and final story
brought to you by Billy yes it is so
happy to hear that Jackie self-care and
routines are always important whatever
you're using to get ready for the day
should make you feel amazing so meet
Billy they've recreated everyday
essentials by delivering premium razors
and high-performing body care directly
to you know pink tax no visit to the
drugstore and no breaking the bank go to
my Billy dot-com to get their starter
kit for just nine dollars that includes
their award-winning razor to refill
blades and a magnetic holder that keeps
your razor safe and dry in between uses
that's the best part about Billy is this
magnetic holder like literally no more
razor like falling on the ground it's
just so special and Billy's out there to
change the way that you shave they just
released three completely clean products
that are must-have adds to your routine
a lip balm a dry shampoo and they
wash face wipes excuse me um everything
that Billy makes is just everything in
the store like the packaging is so cute
the products when Margot got her first
rate so she was like Claudia like you
need this razor it's the best phrase
they're like how is this different from
all of the razors she was like you just
need it and I got the razor and she's
right it just is so far superior the
magnetic the magnetic holder like keeps
it from getting like moldy and rusty and
crusty and it's just I can't explain it
why but it's just a better racer it's a
cleaner shape it's a closer shave it's a
softer shape it's just everything of the
sort
it really is they're in a lower best of
beauty winner and nylons beauty hit list
for a reason if you want to get the
starter kit go to my Billy com that's my
bi L Li comm slash toast where you can
get the best razor you'll ever own for
just nine dollars to get your starter
kit plus free shipping you've got to go
to my Billy dot-com slash toast my bi ll
i a dot-com slash toast to get the best
razor you'll ever own for just $9.99 do
with just that very important segment
didn't find the story it is a little
business ok tick-tock taps Disney
executive Kevin Meyer as their new CEO
the head of Disney Plus streaming
service will lead the video app owned by
by tenants as his Chinese company seeks
global expansion
so Kevin mayor who was passed over for
the top job at Walt Disney Co you know
the one who would take over for Bob Iger
is becoming chief executive of tick-tock
and a jump from one of the entertainment
industry's most it be nerble names to
one of its busiest numerals I think this
is so interesting so this is the guy who
launched Disney Plus and he didn't get
the job of CEO and now he's go he's
taken his towns to tick tock honestly
good you know you have to know your
worth you do have to know your Worth and
I hope this means like really exciting
improvements for tick tock even though
like I don't even know what they need no
it's the perfect platform I spent all
morning on it um I I think a lot of
people are just like concerned or like
the only we like discussion around tick
tock is like it's the biggest
the world that can it last so I think
it's great that they're having someone
from Disney who's like from an
established company like a long-lasting
company come over hopefully he can bring
some of that stability to tik-tok
because musically was like everything of
the sort until it wasn't you know ya
know it definitely I think tick tock
wouldn't probably be worried about just
like burning out like is this really
just like a quarantine hobby um I think
that they have all the makings of being
a forever sort of platform but they
definitely have to make the right moves
at this time
yeah I agree they I foresee you know and
not that I know anything but I do
foresee it being like a stagnant
platform where like people are just
gonna always have one like in facebook
it when it's roomy but I talk yeah I can
put that I'd like to talk so it's a good
platform that's the tea that's that on
that should be driving to our TV recap
second yes we should okay I want to hear
about what were you just saying that you
watched oh the Seinfeld special yes so
it's called 23 hours left and first of
all it was just fabulously done he had
like a full orchestra onstage at the
beacon the lights like it was really
like old Hollywood glamour um and the
first like 20 minutes
me and Ben were dying it was just really
Seinfeld a like talking about just how
difficult everything is like he's like
even you guys came here to my show
tonight like ticket to get the tickets
in or should I pick you up like it was
all the intricacies of like how leaving
the house is terrible and how everything
you do you only do it so that you can
come back home yeah it was like so funny
me and Ben were dying and then it just
stopped
it just completely stopped being funny
and it was weird because like Seinfeld
is very specific he is I would like an
older demographic like really like
Jewish humor um and I felt like he just
started talking about like cell phones
and like social media just like in an
attempt to like be relevant I don't even
know it just felt so unnatural and it
was so not funny it was literally like
local Vegas comedy opener like it was
there were some jokes like I was just
and it was so strange because he's so
funny and I and he does this like clean
type of humor it's like not vulgar which
I really like and he's been like one of
my favorite comedians and like we were
dying at first
like and then I look at Ben and like we
haven't laughed in like 10 minutes
it just it came to a halt and it's
because it was just like why sure he
signs out talking about your phone being
in your pocket and like it's like it
just it made no sense and I just like we
eventually turned it off um and I'm sure
picked back up I go every set of comedy
like has highs and lows but the low was
just so long that we just couldn't get
back into it
Wow okay I want to watch the first 20
minutes out though yeah it was so funny
it was so been like and it just really
it's like 23 hours left it's like
everything in the life is so long and
hard and I just I thought that was gonna
be the whole special like I totally
relate especially in quarantine like I
totally relate to that concept that like
everything is just difficult people are
difficult and you hate your friends but
you don't wanna go make new friends so
you just stick with the old ones like it
was so funny and then it just it was
like a different comedian stepped
onstage wow that is so interesting okay
I will definitely be there yeah and
that's all I watch oh and then we went
and watched some old we just like wanted
to watch something funny watching my old
Chappelle um
stand-up which was it was crazy honestly
like I can just can't believe he said
some of the stuff that he says you know
oh which one did you watch it was called
the bird revelation or something I don't
know okay would you recommend it
honestly no like I'm not even like PC
police but it was really make it like
some of it was like making me
uncomfortable he talked a lot about
louis c.k um and but he also spoke about
how we know he knew a lot of the stuff
that he was saying was crazy and wrong
but he just wants to say it because we
ins have a responsibility to be reckless
and to be offensive so like I got it but
it's just some of the stuff as like a
woman I just said couldn't get on board
with it at the same time he's also like
such like a champion in a woman it makes
no [ __ ] sense like he was just
talking about like and then he ended
like it was just a little all over the
place like I couldn't decide like what
side he was taking in anything which I
think it was the point um but so like as
someone who believes that like comedians
should be able to joke about things like
I was here for a but like as a woman I
was like not here for a lot of the stuff
Oh God okay now I'm now I'm just curious
to watch it but um I probably won't know
it was very country
if it doesn't come highly recommend it
like I can barely even watch this stuff
I'm excited about watching ya know I
don't know if I would like 100%
recommend it like there were parts that
were so funny but like I just had like a
little bit of a pit the whole time
understood
do you see the politician season - you
got a release date June 19th I'm so
excited
me too hopefully like we'll be out of
the house by then and I'll be too busy
to watch it but at this rate no one
really knows hopefully I'll be watching
it like alfresco while I'm dining
alfresco um yeah just the prospect of
which makes me so excited I know it's
really crazy um watching like so many
states are opening up or things are like
moving and it's just we're living in a
different world
you know ya know like I'm like people
are really making strides like the curve
has been flattened a few restaurants are
choosing business owners are choosing to
open if they feel safe because they're
now now allowed to and I just like I
don't know what planet I'm on because
it's not that one no and like no one has
that choice here but you know it's the
beginning of the week and so I'm I'm
starting off on a good foot you know I
put on a river today just to stay in my
house and so we'll be patient yes did
you watch anything you want to recap um
I'm not finished with money heist yet so
there's not that much that I want to say
but I don't know it's just like the
trope of the show is just getting like
exhausting at some point the hostages I
know that no one is going to kill them
like you can just walk out the front
door um like that like in the first
siege this spoiler it's like they don't
kill hostages they're not there they're
not murderers I'm not there to kill
people and like I know what we're
supposed to be on the side of the
professor and his squad um but at the
end of the day like they're criminals
and they're thieves and so every time
like something goes against them like
I'm like excited that the police are
winning so like it's really like the
Super Bowl I whichever team wins is the
team that I wanted to win because I
really don't give a [ __ ] but you know
whose time is it summertime no it's not
their time Oh whose time yeah you said
it sooner
Oh remember time oh wait no no it was
the cheeps time and we other one the
other one was the what city did we
offend San Francisco San Francisco I
think we did offend San Francisco that
sounds that sounds about right
I don't even wasn't there time it wasn't
there time that's the thing
but this super what's so crazy is this
super what was just like a month before
the key oh yeah no I was like two months
ago no but like it feels like years ago
when I started at the toe stop was
freezing I'd literally put a blanket on
my legs and I've never been hotter
that's great you worked up a sweat yes I
did before we let it bring up anything
we want to promote two new episodes of
our patreon Channel podcast episodes
dear toasters and then a tailor's 15
episode there are new episodes of TNN
shows coming out all week there was a
new episode all day night no girls night
remember we rebranded yes and just tons
of new stuff get your Jackie O Flo
Jackie O Flo compromise comedy special
on iTunes the link is in my bio on
Instagram girl with no job anything else
um nothing just premium content coming
at you all week per usual so make sure
you're following along and that is all
she wrote she let me know her hand hurts
and she is [ __ ] done for the day
that's a testy like you don't want it
you don't want to push her lemons thank
you so much for listening to the morning
trust the millennium morning show we go
live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time on YouTube so if you're
watching us on YouTube please feel free
to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast anywhere podcast we found that
Spotify iTunes stitcher Public Radio I
don't really catch all the places
whoever you listen to podcast find us
good morning joseline five star B about
our beautiful stunning and smart we are
we love you guys so much we'll see you
tomorrow I'm done bye
[Music]